je rappelle que nous gagnons ce sera
chez moi on sera filmé 24 24 et passera
tout un week end à la maison voilà parce
que c'est jean michel mr 2e thierry
moreau troisième est de ramallah gré et
ensuite c'est le peloton roulant pour la
proclamation moi j'avais signé hier et
on nous rajoute pas mais trois points ça
va pas du tout quel point ouais t'as dit
oui mais j'y vais mais j'y vais j'y vais
pas te dis que par ça mais là mais tu me
vois tu moi parce que je bouge si si je
mens je pars tu vois plus tu que janot
qui jaloux le nouveau technicien du
plateau l'a sûrement par l'eba je suis
content d'être ici et ben ouais ouais
ouais je m'occupe de s'en excuser moi il
faut que je m'occupe de la micro à
prendre même problème au pot la caisse
c'est ce petit cul de tennisman là et
c'est du boulot de compétition allait
lever le même que c'est beyonce de tunis
et trois sets alors qu'est ce que vous
voulez en direct oui c'est le principal
ça veut dire c'est à dire si je dis un
truc que là il ya tout le monde de
cliquer même temps on peut pas le couple
exactement moi c'est le direct et actuel
directeur mais je vous le dis alors je
vous adore monsieur doigt sur des
supports super content mais par contre
je vous le dis comme ça il ya les
cinémas pathé gaumont qu'un de
téléphoner faut ramener le fauteuil et
oui j'adorerais ça va ma merde
vous pouvez y aller non alors maintenant
je suis je suis pas parti il ya une
mauvaise nouvelle ce qu est ce que je
peux est ce que je peux vous je vous le
dis bien que je vous adore on m'a déjà
laissé le terrain quand vous faites le
choc comme ça de la truite là je me
régale et ça rime c'est une truite petit
bras la crème est ce que je peux dire
beaujoire money doit le jeu sera jouable
et s'écrie je boive sait qu'il peut
profiter à thierry moreau [ __ ]
série monsieur moreau vous êtes un génie
vovan si c'est tellement de la merde
[ __ ] je me disais un truc pour vous un
poids économique un peu les choses
pourquoi vous acier pas directement dans
le pull up vous attendez quand vous avez
une bonne vanne on vous dit tu rentres
tu as oui cela n'est apparemment
monsieur monsieur amish mais je me
schirm est rien le problème quand on
sera pas là il est mûr à ce que je me
disais ouais ouais donc qu'il en parle
beaucoup mais bon ils viennent pas
toujours avec l'aja reviennent pas je
pensais pas qu'un jour je serai ici vous
je joue je vous adresse vous le dire
était normal si vous avez besoin de
quelque chose jadot pour me demander
n'importe quoi
vous l'aurez pas me vous l'aurez demandé
avant tout les artistes que vous avez
lancé il paraît qu'à l'époque vous avez
lancé mimie mathy alors que c'est
interdit
il n'y a pas de petits réglages à faire
sur le micro des noix non parce que je
suis devant son micro et non ok mais il
y en a deux des droits ce soir à la
force bleus fort ce rouge et noir
je voulais dire jouer moi je suis fan de
vous je vous trouve belle comme tout et
vous êtes tous pour moi vous êtes le
parfait mélange entre charlize theron et
joey starr mais oui non mais ça ça bouge
pas normal massa css et conçu par la
nasa a été testé en soufflerie ça
résiste à mcdo mc3 normalement je
vérifie pour faire plaisir aux gens
normal ça bouge pas franchir la tâche je
vérifie bennani c'est sa 4e cape town a
pris un coup de soleil sont même pas de
béthanie rivaliser mais partage qui
n'est pas de la ciotat
non non parce que j'ai un copain qui
s'appelle un partage qui tamponne une
valérie
il s'attend à ne s'attend pas une
certaine presse à tampa ne s'attend pas
le mec tu avais pas la poste devront
mouiller ça te plairait tempéré se
régale
elle adore athée je l'appelais mon
copain loulou parce qu'il connaît tous
nolan touche tous les dossiers de la
ciotat icaunais loulou la cij amour je
sus je suis à touche pas à mon poste a
essayé et je travaille touche pas à mon
poste tout mais si le pakistanais les
simpson j'y suis mais moins vite mais la
vitre gardes royaux à côté je suis rien
d'acquis d un put à dire que jamais il
ya quinze ans il fait saquer de sa caste
affiché hiver et les retours mais un
même examen nouveau big boss qu un petit
aux dames qui viennent ultrasons latu
salle à l'autre jour à l'après fous
rires tous les chiens du quartier qui
sans régler son jeu le dommage je lui
demande d'où ils me demandent bionz et
le demande y avait pas de petits jeunes
qui devaient venir aujourd'hui faire à
sa première leurs pertes c'est bien pâle
n'a pas bien moi je ne faisais pas ne
touche pas on passe le forum page va le
voir à l'europe et metz qui joue les
jeudi vendredi samedi à 21h30 et les
places se vendent comme des petits pains
à l'âge
merci temps merci d'avoir été là